To apply stimulation in real life and to apply optimization in real life,
we have to have an idea about the sources and the amounts of errors that we are introducing.
The model as such may not be good enough.
For instance, we may be missing some vital effects in that model.
The values that we are using for the model's parameters may be wrong.
We may be using the wrong growth rate or we may be using the growth rate that's too big
or we may be using a maximum carrying capacity that's too large.
The initial data may be off. Do we really know the amount of fish we're starting with?
And we may have numerical issues, maybe due to round off errors
or maybe, which is more probable, due to finite step sizes.
We look at numerics in Units 2 and 3.
I'll discuss the problems with this model at the end of these units.
What I want to consider now is how to study errors concerning the parameters and initial data.
The nice thing about these is that we can check them in the model.
We can use a computer to get an idea about the effects
at least of errors we are introducing here,
and the computer can help us to find out which of these parameters and initial data
is the most critical concerning its range of uncertainty.
If we try to get more certain data, which of these would we try to improve?
That's one of the major objectives of sensitivity analysis.